[Music]
so we just did a video on Godzilla's new
evolved form as seen in the trailer of
Godzilla and Kong the new Empire and now
it's time for the monkey man The Big Ape
we will discuss how Kong has changed
here in this video meaning his design
his size and how he would lose his main
weapon the axe and get a new one in the
form of the Power Fist or the monster
infity Gauntlet as we would like to call
it so let's get to it let's start with
his size first uh there isn't much of a
difference that one can see here with
his height as compared to the GVK
version well firstly Kong was 103 ft or
31.7 M tall when we first saw him in the
2017 movie called Skull Island which
actually happened in the 1970s as the
events of that movie are to be
considered then he grew fast like super
fast man juicing up with Skull Island
protein balls and Squid meals he was
around 200 ft or 60 M tall by the time
of the birth of Kong in the 1990s just
20 years afterwards then he was later
stated to be 270 ft or 82 M when he
fought with chots in the Kingdom Kong
comics and finally 337 ft or 103 m in
GVK so we don't really know if he would
grow again again just a little bit in
gxk or if he had maxed out in GVK you
know but one thing I can say if the
hollow Earth radiation would have some
sort of effect it might push him to 350
or so by the events of the new
Empire now let's take a look at his
design well unlike Godzilla Kong
wouldn't and will not undergo through
any kind of evolution phase nor will he
be mutated by the radiation or form a
crysalis or a cocoon he will retain the
same basic shape and physique one thing
that can change though is his beard he
looks to have a longer goatee in the
trailer The Big Ape looks like a full-on
viking with it and the A and what makes
it even more sexy is the presence of a
thicker coat of fur on his shoulder and
back which makes him look even more
Viking he seems to have become a silver
back type you know the alpha male of a
gorilla family the largest one who has a
different type of fur coloration and
thickness to Showcase his Supremacy in
the pack Kong here also has grown a
thicker fur coat with silver highlights
which thus showcases that he has reached
his Peak maturity age now that we are
done with discussing about his body and
size let's take a look at the other
interesting features about him his
weapons so in the trailer we saw quite a
few scenes of Kong and the hollow Earth
running without any weapon or running
with a weapon he was also seen with the
axe in other scenes on the hollow Earth
like meeting with the mini Kong and
going down the crevice and he was also
seen surfacing in Egypt from a hollow
Earth entry point in Gaza besides the
pyramids when we first saw him in the
earli scenes of the trailer he merged
out with an augmented arm that is with a
metal frame akin to a power fist or yeah
the monster infity Gauntlet this
artificial armed arm also bore a
yellowish color somehow reminding us of
Bumblebee from the Transformers movies
this powerfist would definitely be human
made probably created by Monarch for
Kong in case he lost his main weapon or
needed some sort of a cast for a broken
arm either way the metal arm would have
already been in existence before he
really needed it it would have been a
backup plan a device a weapon um
thing but now the question arises how
does Kong lose such a weapon like the
axe and get a power fist wouldn't the
axe be one of the most priced possession
and yeah he definitely would not forget
such a valuable relic of his past
meaning that he wouldn't be absent
minded so how does this happen I
personally think that Kong would lose
this in a fight in the middle of the
movie probably in a face off against
either scar King with shimu or against a
pack of Titan wolves that were chasing
him as you can see in the trailer when
the Wolves were chasing after Kong he
neither had the ax with him nor did he
have any type of power yet but this was
as said in a leaked information from the
ones that have seen the earlier
screenings of the movie that this scene
of the Wolves were quite early on in the
movie so maybe he didn't carry the axe
where he went at that time and yet in
the latest scenes when he was exploring
the hollow Earth including the time when
he discovered the ancient MK grave of
his ancestors he had the weapon with him
so how does one lose such a mighty
weapon which was so important to him
defeating Mecha Godzilla and putting up
a fight against Godzilla in GVK okay
well I think personally that Kong would
be exploring the hollow Earth and meets
with a small baby red ape the mini Kong
and then find out what really happened
to his ancestors you know in the scene
where he climbed down a large crevice
which had tons of skulls and skeletons
of dead Kongs he would be in shock as to
the fate of these individuals who are
probably killed in a gruesome way either
cannibalized by the scar king or or
thrown down the cave as a sacrific to a
deadly ancient primordial entity the
Titan shimu so this might also be how
scaring gain Supremacy over the other
Kongs over the other tribes of Kongs by
the use of sacrifices to gain an
alliance with shimu but this will be a
topic which we shall discuss in detail
in another
video yeah so I think that Kong would
eventually have a face off with the scar
King in an attempt to rescue or save
other captive Kongs and that small red
mini Kong the fight will be brutal but
since Kong is in his prime in his silver
back age he would dominate a fight
against the oldest caring who although
is much more experienced and way more
cunning would eventually lose to a more
youthful successor but before Kong
delivers the winning blow shimu would
emerge and save the scar King thus
revealing a threat like none other a
team up of two talents of different
species each making up for the weakness
of the other like pieces of a puzzle and
I believe that it would be here that
Kong would lose his weapon and have his
arm broken only to narrowly escape to
safety thus as they said in the trailer
Kong can't do this on his own and so he
will have to seek out his rival for help
and in the meanwhile he will get an
upgrade with a monster Infinity Gauntlet
which would give Kong's broken arm some
respite from the injury and also serve
as a power fist enhancing the deadliness
of the Big A
sponges anyway that's what I think would
happen to Kong in the movie how he would
lose his ax and get the gauntlet so if
you like this video then watch this
other one as well and do check out our
channel for other monsterverse content
we might just have things that you
haven't seen before so like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next video take
care fam